hello good night mike hi mike it's about
what time is it uh one p.m it's a little
one a few minutes after a pound after
one
a little bit after one minute
today we're going to be making uh what
is it thanksgiving cookoff
thanksgiving dinner this is me look i'm
wearing my thanksgiving shirt
for this cookoff it's a thanksgiving
dinner with me mites and
is the second big mood cook-off last
time
it was gina and jess competing cooking
breakfast
yeah cooking breakfast you can go watch
that vlog uh they were competing
for tiff and i to judge against it and a
lot of the comments oh
how the turntables have turned
get ready for a level four rating on
your food
because i'm salty i got a seven actually
six
the reason you got a six was because
your food was unsalty oh
tips that it was too
so this time we are doing thanksgiving
side dishes
side dishes whoever makes the best side
dish wins and it's going to be between
mickey and tiffy yeah we just brought a
chicken oh you bought it bro i got extra
points
because i brought the chicken the
pumpkin pie and the salad
the salad i get extra points because i
brought all the booze
oh that's the extra extra points yeah
yeah yeah i get extra points because i'm
wearing the things giving out
okay okay okay okay i get extra voice
because because because because i
brought an
apron and that's like what your cat lady
oh but i guess i get the extra points
because it's not thanksgiving theme
yeah i'm gonna give you extra points
because
like thanksgiving is kind of an
insensitive cultural holiday
don't say that don't say that in front
of the colonizer don't do that don't do
that
taking away from my
that's culture too so it's in you
thanksgiving is important because it's
right near my birthday that's all i care
about oh
then doesn't overshadow your birthday
this is a birthday
friend look we made her birthday cookies
there we go
birthday christmas cookies oh i've got
all the ingredients for the cookies so
nice they're winning nothing because i
don't know why they're trying so hard
honestly
all right let's start cooking what
happened
i forgot the main ingredient what
what i'm making cornbread i forgot the
cornmeal
oh my gosh
literally everything else i brought a
mixer a bowl i went
pre-measured my flour and salt and sugar
from the last cookoff gina forgot all of
her ingredients and she ended up winning
no i only forgot
i only forgot she was gay that's it
she's out of the quesadilla that's true
are you gonna go to the store
[ __ ] you only have a car here again it's
just again
and we're off yes now we have to go down
this
crazy i know look how bumpy it is look
at this road it's like we're in the
middle
of tj pretty much it reminds me of
back home you know with my family's oh
[ __ ]
i'm like what are we doing oh i think
he's parking this
is this is crazy i think this
neighborhood is not really quite like
that nice but somehow the art
the house that we're running is pretty
nice yeah that's what happens when
people gentrify
true because yeah look at this
this is crazy and yeah on the other side
there's like an entire
cliff that we could possibly fall from
but that's
that's the price we pay because uh we
gotta go get this cornmeal
and then nikki stayed behind because she
has to prepare
for our murder mystery video that we're
gonna be filming later today
so that's why she's staying a lot of
stuff to read still yeah
poor poor nicki man she was like beating
herself up for forgetting this
yeah she brought so much like she
brought a whole bunch of other stuff so
she was bound for yeah she was making
them by scratch too which i'm like i
would never have done that yeah just buy
jiffy in the box
i i don't even step foot in the kitchen
at all so that's
true the fact that she's even doing all
that i wonder if she has
sugar for them because she said she
brought she brought flour and she has
powdered sugar i'm pretty sure she has
everything else okay if not she would
have let us know
look they're back okay my competition
helped me
get my missing ingredients so i feel
like you do get points for that
i get it very sad but also happy
hey it's conflicting judges determine
the question we're giving each other
we don't need you tim you get points for
that i hope you win
for being beautiful oh my god how many
what all right here we go back to
cooking
so since you know i helped you out um
and like you cooked yeah like i never do
what is eight ounces of this oh my gosh
um well usually you would have a scale
if you were going to do eight ounces but
a whole pound so i mean you know how
many ounces are in a pound
so maybe half of the body yeah yes
yes sure do i boil
um i usually fill the pot up like food
it literally doesn't matter mira mira
mira
and then and salt it okay and then um
once it's
boiling wait for it to boil and then
once it's boiling
pour enough like half like i would yeah
like
half yeah and then
you kind of stir it occasionally you
don't have to be constantly stirring it
but
you let it sit there for like seven
minutes oh and then it's seven what does
it say
it's gonna say seven to ten minutes i
don't know follow the recipe
okay the recipe yes
but then i got nervous because i'm like
what's it else
i'm not confident about my recipe either
uh these judges are very hungry
and i'm really excited to see their
disappointment
my dad makes really good cornbread oh oh
god you can't beat my dad's porn
editor edit out this lecture i brought a
cast iron skillet from home oh my god
it's heavy as [ __ ] points thank you
plus 10 points for the caption
hey i brought my own part two she
brought pot
it's just b-rolled them on their phones
while they were supposed to be cooking
cookies
what's happening these boulders
i can't get my recipe to pull out it's
been like 10 minutes
so for some reason the wi-fi will not
work with nikki it won't work
it hates me that's weird what phone do
you have
you have an eight no oh my god maybe
that's why
nikki it's time are we are you poor are
you poor
are you ready we're gonna start a
gofundme for you
what's how are you doing with an eight
nicky are we on like a 12 right that's
why i need to win this competition chip
chef i have seven mouths to feed at home
six of them are cats
one is a husband that only survives on
monster energy drinks
and i can only afford that food see this
that's why it doesn't work
i have to weigh in on this minus eight
points
for the iphone eight eight for eight
yeah got it
sympathy doesn't work on me that's why
the wi-fi won't connect it's like
i gave you a point thank you the wi-fi
is i don't want to connect to this
old-ass dinosaur
she's back up and running back back in
the game
but i'm still poor so please donate to
my gofundme okay
are you done yet you're hungry it's
ready
oh what is it what the hell is this holy
water this egg replacer
ah right right right right right right
right right right right right i gotta
get it
what you got in here water water
delicious
i'm never gonna eat i'm gonna die i die
by the time they're done
it's too loud we're never gonna boil
this [ __ ] water
maybe one day i'll be able to eat she
said it's too
loud we have to boil water it's too
loud check where we go
you may enter the elbow macaroni into
the water okay you said half
what is half let me see it doesn't
matter what is half
baby i hate it here
oh [ __ ] look at this giant whisk oh my
god you remember
jesus that tiny spatula
they should meet they should meet
sometimes just making a cornbread
figure more we're gonna be more than
that lady
no the recipe calls for eight ounces you
can always
find can you make extra because i like i
like
i like i like raw potty yeah there you
go hopefully there's enough cheese
that's what i'm talking about i don't
know what uh i like raw pasta i mean
like not raw pots
unsalted pasta anyways just eat elbow
macaroons yeah
dry by itself hey you want to do some
sugar
this is so weird okay
oh yeah baby
it's a private moment so i was saying
i'm like i haven't been in the kitchen
in like eight years
how am i supposed to know these things
jeff didn't want to turn up the
she wanted to turn can i turn it down
now
i don't know you have to boil
isn't it gonna like like burn the
[ __ ] i don't know
the water isn't it
the water burn the water
this is the audacity to give me a
six on my toast and she can't even
boil water she said burn the water
god bless almighty jesus so angry
can you burn hair i need a redo no you
can't burn your hair
can you burn i'm done i'm out of here oh
my god
vicky you know you just went you're fine
like everyone
what happened here what happened nothing
to see this thing
fell out okay where's the where's the
colander get it get it ready
i know i was gonna i don't know
we did we cooked without any help from
these [ __ ]
and she sat there on her high horse and
gave me
i have to take the bus just because i
can't cook
toast it was delicious
avocado egg it was delicious i thought
it was great
oh my god nikki keeps doing oops i know
that's all we hear from nikki
here what's the next step on your recipe
why did you open it i didn't and then
it says empty the pot back onto the butt
set the empty pot back on the stove over
medium heat add the cream bring to a
boil and cook for two to three minutes
until it starts to look slightly thick
you gotta oil your
cast iron skillet you're gonna season it
season it that's something you feel hot
oh it hasn't even been
no they never preheated the oven rookie
mistake
rookie mistake
it's all good everything's ready
everything's fine and dandy it's the end
it's fine and dandy i forgot to put the
cornmeal it's one
third so then mickey
what did you just say no way you got to
do you have something against cornmeal
do you have something against cornmeal
cornmeal you forget to bring it and then
we finally get you something and you
forget to put it in the mixture
let's just look at it like look at it 4
30. you'll get it
what's what do you have broken yellow
things huh
what do you have against yellow things
i ate the yellow cookies you ate the
yellow cookie
cookie that looks like gina and i
ate it i knew it i knew it she's always
treated me different
i knew it that's it i'm jealous you and
me buddy we're gonna hang out together
we don't need this we don't need this
buddy
i definitely need that she needs us more
than we need her yellow thing
right mickey i need you both let's jump
in the walls
are you licking raw cornmeal batter
no animal i would never she said she's
cleaning it
she eats the oh don't look over here
don't look at me you drink some water i
should call him
okay the cornmeal is definitely in there
now imagine if this thing just broke off
the camera fell straight into the
battery
i would say that that's happened to me
before are you serious
oh god a good thing the oven didn't heat
up all the way i would have put the
batter in there
i was going sweet pea nothing
what does it make sense how's it going
nothing
look at me
suddenly i'm not too confident about
this meal that we're about to have just
i've started to
watch it because should we just post
mates should we just do this in case
i could use this three times it's one
fourth yeah okay we got three whole ass
[ __ ] trying to figure out fractions
it's like fourth grade again three
grown-ass [ __ ] trying to figure out
fractions i would like to say
i don't believe that we are whole
[ __ ] this is true we are
partial three-fourths of a [ __ ]
no absolutely not i'm trying to break
apart the powder
look at the powder nikki look at that i
don't see
though there's a lot oh
the spices it smells great i'm gonna
bite a ball of garlic powder
it would be pretty good all right so
listen i
ended up doubling the recipe because
someone
me gina wanted all of the macaroni i
mean what is this elbows
um and so that made me be three ounces
short of cheddar so that's why it looks
a little too white
you're gonna get lots of pasta less
cheese yep you're gonna get less you're
gonna get mac and mac
we don't have to put all of the cooked
pasta in there yeah sometimes when you
wake up in the middle of night and you
kind of just want a bite of something
and you go to the fridge and there's
just like
plain pasta it's like the best thing to
eat and then you go back to bed
i would at least put some butter i think
if there was cold mac and cheese i'd
take that over the plain pot
sometimes just like the plain pot or
like sometimes i even like like plain
ground cooked around beef
what is this it's a it's tofurky
what does it mean out of corn
what no it's made out of fungus actually
what the [ __ ] is michael protein
just honestly just just i feel like we
should just
we should just decide that she loses
whoa
don't put all of it in there you go
oh my god this is way tip's not allowed
in the kitchen
yeah this is why i don't cook okay that
was bomb though if you wanted a nicky
chipped
coffee give me some of this
more cheese more macaroni no one
remembers courage the cowardly dog when
courage has
babysitted muriel and she's like more
cheese more macaroni
too much macaroni i love that [ __ ] but i
don't remember that what
what smells like burning
that's not you is it i don't think so
don't scare me i mean i'll leave the
microwave
the macaroni on the stove more macaroni
she's been helping me this is a just no
don't add more
careful that's perfect in the oven
i probably need salt i added salt
oh it's like really heavy on the spices
i think i should have added the rest of
the thing
on spices though right put a little bit
more macaroni
hey that's just bomb though yeah
why don't you people use the oven timer
why do you guys always use a microwave
one i don't understand
where the oven timer for the oven who's
cooking in this
in this kitchen i don't know to be
honest right i'm actually not quite sure
anymore
you guys are all helping viewers thank
you for your help
you get points yeah you get points
everybody gets points
to the viewers why are you eating wrong
nothing you know what i feel like you
know what i feel like you know what i
feel like i feel like the mari the mori
cameraman
and you are not the father
these are running happy as they're
running around the
why not give me one good reason why
would you because it tastes
good it's got sugar in it but it's
cornmeal and like
starchy garbage i know just loves canned
cranberry sauce but i've never had it
before
they do too oh really it's like the
mcdonald's
cranberry sauce i don't even know if i
like cranberry sauce period
i usually make my own but it takes like
an hour to like cool down
and i think the canned one just has the
nostalgia childhood that no
fancy one
four four years with an iphone 8
poor grapefruit is that salads
get that [ __ ] out of here
that's the food my food eats
salad that won't focus hello there you
go i got extra points because i made the
salad
i made it i put it together open
the plastic bag with the salad in it
she made it really cute like with the
bowls and everything yeah [ __ ] i
brought this
i bought these books okay okay i made
the salad
minus three points
how long does it take me to roast this
chicken ice cream it took me three days
and um and signature cafe helped me out
with the packaging that was it
not sponsored they just came over custom
packaging
she ordered it this way tonight's a new
moon what does that mean
it means it's time for setting new
intentions and everything that you set
tonight
will come like we'll be in fruition for
the next six months
six months i thought the moon was only
for a 30-day cycle
no it is but it go the with the
attentions that you set out
go for the next six months because of
the planets
all right i gotta send some new
intentions then i i almost thought you
were gonna say i gotta send some nudes
yeah since this needs a new moon
i get it i get it look at the chicken
fat gelatin at the bottom
delicious it's a square ass bird
there we go maybe can you put a tiny bit
of water on the dress i know
i thought about it i was like it looks a
little dry just with your fingers don't
yeah man that's hope berkey looks
amazing
i don't like it i just wanted to eat
look at that oh wow the loaf of how long
is it
whatever see it a chopstick test let's
see it
really come out clean yes
the dog's out here [ __ ]
it looks good yay that vegan
cornbread i mean it just doesn't have it
has almond milk
yeah like most cornbread it's pretty
vegetarian
vegan cornbread they don't get it dried
macaroni is still delicious
that one is really good for some reason
it does taste good so i changed my
opinion
thank you i i still disagree you
literally
eat raw batters on the daily
you better stick it back on there listen
if they get back on there
there's the wing i don't know okay
i'm gonna serve y'all some braids
cornbread
i also forgot butter
hope you like dried cornbread i brought
cranberry sauce i brought carrie sauce
yeah
give yourself some credit ladies but it
would have tasted better with butter and
cranberry sauce
just avoid the broken wings
it's not as pretty macaroni in it
did you say about mac and cheese
sometimes when you make it naturally
like right now it's starting to look
like a little bit closer to a yeast
infection of macaroni and cheese
what i mean not exactly but you get the
idea
i've never had one so thanks for the
visual
little it's a little yeasty
you know it's a little clumpy oh god
yeah
we're about to eat but it's delicious
we are finally being served
i like how we're the judges we're the
judges of this and before
before we even start eating it's just
like now i have a yeast infection stuck
in my head just
judge judges i guess first served first
all right chef tiffany what did you make
for us today i mean macaroni and cheese
with some white pepper and garlic powder
and
uh cheddar delicious delicious cream
delicious delicious
no heavy cream heavy cream heavy cream
i'm just getting stuff thrown onto my
plate
yeah so we're just gonna [ __ ] plating
right guys just [ __ ] please
we're complaining we're playing i'm
trying we're waiting we're blue we're
playing we're playing
we're playing everybody excuse us excuse
me excuse me nature of this plating is
really underpriced instead impressive
it's not a clean plating this is i would
never serve this in my restaurant i
would never
i know you're a restaurant that serves
plain pasta
as a woman you need to stop saying the
word sorry okay sorry
anyone want tofurkey i'll try some i've
never had it before but i want to try it
oh cause i heard it gives you diarrhea
what i haven't pooped you haven't pooped
so maybe you need something
yeah i don't want to need it here judge
yes [ __ ]
she's not ready we have to have both
okay there we go and we learned
everything else all right
you serve yourself a chicken let me try
minus points for whoever brought the
chicken
hey hey hey sorry all i gotta say is
wow i've never had to cut my own chicken
but all right
let's try this try the [ __ ] that we made
first we didn't make the chicken yeah we
made the side dishes
make just a side dishes i want a piece
of chicken
okay you like it do you like it
i like it i give it like a 9.5 oh
wow for someone who never
cooked garlic wow wow she made pasta
everyone
oh wait wait wait wait um
oh minus points there's like a fiber in
it that's fine those fibers from
your
it feels like the cheese and the cream
has kind of like
um yeastified they used to buy chunky
you know when it like separates all
right it's like you broke the cream
i think that's what it's called it's not
bad but the texture is a little off
well so i can't give it a 9.5 if you had
it fresh it would have been way better
yeah but then we had to wait for some
tofurkey
chocolate cornbread crunch cornbread
cornbread
try the one in your lap
yay are you just like cornbread with
some sort of honey or butter
yeah i forgot the butter good yes
it doesn't taste vegetarian at all do
you normally have meat in your cornbread
a milk i can taste almond milk but
besides you can taste the almond milk
baked into the bread
but besides that it's a good texture
hell yeah
it could be sweeter sweeter really it
could be sweeter and more buttery
i don't like myself too sweet but yeah i
could use a little bit of butter from
the salad yeah butter
i totally agree with i should have
brought the earth balance and i did not
i like a honeycomb brand you didn't rate
it
or the macaroon mac and cheese the
flavor is a higher
rating than the texture i'm a little bit
biased because i
love mac and cheese so damn it no no but
you're waiting
on the dish i think i love macaroni
cheese so much that i
can rate it um compared to all the other
mac and cheese
that's what i'm saying yeah yeah you
could compare so all of the macaroni
cheeses prepared everything and
everything
so all the cornbread you've ever tasted
everything
the rating gets a four okay flavor gets
a
7.5 nice okay
so you got like a like a sick five point
five average so six hours
a little bit of and the pepper on
pepperoni hey before you try that
out of out of 10 for the cornbread from
all the cornbreads you've ever tasted
i've had cornbread baby like three times
in my life what i'm not a big corp
we're an asian family cornbread
you can't have this yellow
right i would say the texture on this is
like a
really like a nine yes flavor-wise yeah
it's missing a slight bit of depth but
that's only because people from the
south take the cornbread
very seriously probably but i would give
it
probably an eight hell yes dude
yeah true that's kind of what happened
with yours too did the mac and cheese
higher if i hadn't eaten it
right away yeah yeah it was really good
the texture was bomb right when it was
done i think that's what the box
macaroni and cheese is they have
stabilizers
what's that face topic is not bad right
really
are you serious i'm about to bite into
this
my ancestors are very upset right now
you're eating vegan cornbread and vegan
turkey
that's not too bad i'd eat it again hell
yeah
i taste it it's i'm gonna taste it
tastes like meat
what the hell the texture is a little
strange but it literally tastes like i
have meat in my mouth
wow i love meat in my mouth it's been a
while though huh it's been
three months this is the driest spell
okay i thought it was gonna be like i
was gonna gag but i didn't oh [ __ ]
it's actually pretty good yeah it's kind
of like dog food but like really good
it's like good so the message is if you
wanna trash thanksgiving you don't have
to murder animals
you can um go look at that
well it goes in line with your customs
of your people
sisters
and i and murderers the position
is good hey moist i've only ever smoyed
i've only ever had really dry cornbread
yay i'm so happy
who won
thanks judges you know what okay i'm
thankful for all of you guys
yeah my friend my friends carrying
things for you guys too we love you
i'm also thankful for this wine in the
corner we should have that we should
have some of that
bye everybody subscribe thank you like
the video we love you we're thankful for
you
drink of too cigarette breathe